on my Twitter account at Zoo B music I
posted up a 9 second video of me doing a
deadlift in the gym I was lifting 230
kilograms it's actually well below my
maximum but I just had a clip of me
doing it on my phone and I posted it up
with a caption saying I keep hearing
about how there's no biological
difference between men and women in 2019
so watch me and destroy the British
women's deadlift record without trying
and that I wrote PS I identified as a
woman while lifting the weight so don't
be a bigot and this tweet caught
absolute fire it went hyper viral it's
got 1.7 million views on the original
video I think it got about 55 thousand
likes and 20-something thousand retweets
it just went nuts it went viral in the
UK in Canada in America in Europe like
all over the world
I am joined by the strongest female
deadlift champion on the Internet zoobi
welcome to the show
has gone Chris a lead on fantastic to
have you on man recently spoke to Brian
Carroll who is a multiple record holder
in powerlifting for men and now speaking
to one for women as well that's right
man
deadlift and benchpress 84 kg weight
class women's of course how heavy the
squat what have you got to get you squat
to man I haven't squatted properly for
it for ages because of an injury that's
been harassing me for literally about
five years now but my personal best on
the squat is a hundred and ninety and I
believe the women's record in my weight
class is about 210 something like that a
little bit of work and you've got the
total as well yeah man I think I think I
could do it I could definitely can
completely annihilate the deadlift in
the benchpress ones but um the squad
will take a little bit of work okay so
for everyone who's listening who doesn't
have a clue what we're talking about can
you take us through what's what's
happened over the last few months of
your life yeah the last few months have
been quite the whirlwind so um going
back to February now at the end of
February on my Twitter account at zoobi
music I posted up a 9 second video of me
doing a deadlift in the gym I was
lifting 230 kilograms which is five
hundred and something pounds it's
actually well below my maximum but I
just had a clip of me doing it on my
phone and I posted it up with a caption
saying I keep hearing about how there's
no biological difference between men and
women in 2019 so watch me destroy the
British women's deadlift record without
trying and that I wrote PS I identified
as a woman while lifting the weight so
don't be a bigot and this tweet caught
absolute fire it went hyper viral it's
got 1.7 million views on the original
video I think it got about 55 thousand
likes and 20 something thousand retweets
it just went nuts it went viral in the
UK in Canada in America in Europe like
all over the world and then newspapers
and media started picking up on it it
was covered by Fox News The Daily wire
Sky News BBC
a whole bunch of different outlets and
then a bunch of podcasts such as louder
with Crowder the ben shapiro show and
the one that really catalyzed a few
things which was the Joe Rogan
experience so it just it just went
bonkers at the time I tweeted it I had
17,000 followers and as of this week I'm
the proud owner of over a hundred I
don't say owner I'm the proud yeah well
I have over a hundred thousand Twitter
followers now so it's increased just
crazily they see air as well as my
YouTube audience and my podcast audience
and my music listeners everything I do
has just exploded it was a real catalyst
for everything I do which is awesome but
also kind of ridiculous ya know this
kind of real asymmetry with viral
content and stuff like that is a it's a
real blessing when you get it right and
what's hilarious is the fact that this
is you working up to like an RP 7 that's
like that's like a comfortable 75% pull
I don't know whether anyone's discussed
this yet but we haven't we've had a
number of debates on the podcast about
why the pulling sumo is cheating or not
no it's not no it's not it's not even
easier for everybody well there we go
we've heard it I mean if it were if it
were easy when people say it's easier
I'm like then why don't you pull it it's
it's competition legal yep so if if it
were easier every single power lifter
would pull sumo but they don't so agreed
it's kind of silly logic to even say
that I mean it depends on how you're
built for some people it is easier mm-hm
but um not for everybody or every I mean
if you even look at the sort of world
strongest men guys most of them don't
pull sumo yeah
or anything isn't it yeah most most of
them don't it really depends on your
build your sort of leg to arm ratio your
hips all that kind of stuff so yeah
we've got a very tall co-host on the
show Johnny who pulls 310 and in the
hundred and three hundred fives whatever
it is
he pulls sumo but we we just want him up
by saying that's sometimes I can do both
by the way yeah just anyone one nice
that's funny so this has happened it's
absolutely exploded and what has that
done in terms of exposure for York
now because having to look through your
Twitter and I strongly advise everyone
who's listening to go and check out a
zoo be music because it is the caliber
of that content doesn't smack of someone
who only had sort of 17,000 followers a
few months ago it's very insightful very
well curated for Twitter bulleted list
some some very nice sort of social
commentary all that sort of stuff so
what was the grind up to that point what
was happening up to that Wow
well so I'm a professional rapper I'm an
independent musician I've been doing it
full-time since 2011 but I've been
rapping since 2006 so if you go on my
Twitter profile you see my Twitter has
been active since July 2009 and before
that I was on Facebook and YouTube and
before that I was on MySpace if you want
to take it back to the beginning so I've
been I've been active on social media
for a very long time I've been building
my audience for a long time primarily
through my music and my my gigs and my
concerts and selling CDs traveling all
around the UK whether that's down in
Bournemouth or the Isle of Wight or up
in Newcastle or Glasgow I've been to
every city in the UK multiple times
doing shows selling my CDs talking to
people just promoting my music so that
was the thing that I was initially known
for and that's the main way that I built
up my organic audience so it's been a
really long grind to get to where things
are I mean I've released five albums and
three EPS I've got eight releases and
total out there those are all available
on iTunes and Spotify and all that sold
over 25,000 albums out of my backpack
just travelling around the UK put out a
ridiculous number of I mean I've got
55,000 tweets on my adjust on my Twitter
and then crazy amounts of content on
Facebook and YouTube and all these
different places so it's all been um I
mean it's been great because because I
laid such a strong foundation it meant
that when that tweet went viral people
it meant two things or maybe more than
two things number one is that people
came and a lot of them stayed because
they realized that I had a lot more to
offer beyond just what
funny kind of silly tweet all right
people go viral all the time on Twitter
but they don't have 100,000 followers
because the tweet goes viral but then
people go to the page and there's
nothing particularly interesting there
beyond that one-off funny tweet so
people don't really follow and people
disappear with mine
you know people came and then they were
like oh oh he's a rapper Oh his music is
actually good oh he's a does podcast so
he's I like his podcast oh he's got
interesting stuff to say and he's funny
so a lot of people came and they stayed
and then also it just meant that I've
been able to deal with some of the
craziness
you know the massive amount of love and
attention massive amounts of hate and
criticism I've been dealing with both of
these things as a professional musician
for well over a decade so I'm kind of
season to it all that's happened is that
the volume has increased which is
something I'm still adjusting to and the
volume is going to increase again so in
a way it's kind of what I wanted it's
just it's just odd how it happened you
know that that was of all the content
I've put out there all the things I've
done of all the money I've spent of all
the traveling I've done the idea that it
was that ridiculous tweet they didn't
even have anything to do with my music
to open so many people up to Who I am
and what I do that you know it's it's
been very bizarre but um I'm thankful
for it yeah when you're grinding away
five years ago ten years ago in a studio
in the ass-end of London somewhere he's
trying to get the same verse 20 times
and then all you should have really been
doing is just working on you see my
deadlift form and well one of my friends
one of my friends Jose made a really
good point he said you know what man it
took you 15 years of training to even
make that video nice right so he was
like you know it
that wasn't an overnight like most
people cannot lift what you just lifted
so most people would not be able to even
make that video so I was actually you
know when you when you think of it that
way that does make a lot of sense it's
quite it's quite a good metaphor I guess
in way that it can look like something
just oh I'm just gonna do this thing but
it's actually not a lot of people are
able to do that
things they didn't put in the groundwork
beforehand so what might be easier for
that one person just like the guy you
were talking about earlier who can squat
over a thousand pounds right I'm sure
for him doing that it's not going to
look particularly difficult but the
average person okay not know that rich
person can't even do a quarter of that
so yeah yeah so uh yeah but that's
that's how the world works man I get you
so one of the quotes that I really love
is look equals preparation plus
opportunity and I think that that
definitely seems to kind of be what's
happened and a lot of the podcasts and
people that you've been on with recently
have focused on the issues and what what
the actual narrative is around that and
we can go into that in a second
but for people that are listening and
you know everyone who has a wouldn't
some degree of upward mobility and is on
that grind is hoping for that moment
right that breakout moment but what
you've identified there are things
really interesting which is that the
same way as someone who's a stonemason
working away with a hammer and a chisel
it's not the hundredth strike which
actually breaks the stone it's the 99
that came before that and you totally
correct with what you say that it's all
well and good being handed an
opportunity and having this super viral
moment I recently wrote a blog that said
actually there's a fairly high
likelihood of everyone or most people a
significant majority of people going
viral to one degree or another at some
point now because of the way the degrees
of separation' work online I mean like
okay cool like that gives you a platform
and that is an opportunity but if you
are just going to hope that that I don't
know create some springboard out of
nowhere and there's no substance behind
it the preparation hasn't allowed you to
get ready for the opportunity there's
nothing in this I think there's like a
real amount of poetic justice that's
kind of a despite the fact that
obviously you've worked a lot harder on
other things than pulling like so you
know you've had a lot of time to view
this from a front row seat what do you
think that the reaction to the tweet
that you put out what did what do you
think it says is it as a commentary have
you got an overall conclusion of how
that how its
you feel your thoughts at the moment I
would say that the thing I'm really I've
really picked up on over the last few
years but especially over the last few
months is I've become I guess more of a
public figure and a better known person
is that there are so many people who
feel silenced
shall we say so so many people were very
thankful for that tweet cousin they've
been seeing stuff going on and they're
like oh my gosh like things are getting
absurd things are getting ridiculous
objective reality is being disposed of
and whatever there's millions of people
around the world are feeling that if not
billions of people and so that tweet was
just something that very in an in a
visual way and in a satirical way just
exposed some of the silliness in the
world that people are aware of right so
this whole idea of like I said in the
comment you know the idea of men and
women not being different or having the
same physical and strength capabilities
right some of these ideas or the idea
that a man like myself with my beard and
my muscles can identify as a woman and
everybody is supposed to just accept
that I'm a woman and not question it and
allow me to compete in women's sports
and play rugby against them in box
against them and lift deadlift against
them and all that right that some people
are saying this from an ideological
perspective trying to say that I'll find
it
the vast majority people do not agree
with that the vast majority of people
are like no that's ridiculous that
doesn't make sense that's not based in
reality but for various reasons and
societal pressures they feel like they
can't express that or if they can't
express it they can only do it on a very
small platform or perhaps in private so
by me putting that out there it was kind
of like everybody exhaled I think you
know I think people finally someone just
said it and showed it yeah right that's
visual as well so it's like you
I think it's one thing if you read
something that's nothing the video the
video as well just the fact that people
saw it and it was a very clear rebuttal
yeah these arguments that people make so
it was like okay no he wasn't actually
trying during that death and I'm not a
professional lifter yeah I'm not I'm not
competing in powerlifting or Strongest
Man or whatever there's loads of guys
who are considerably stronger than me so
the fact that I a recreational lifter
can just go and shatter the woman's
records as could many other recreational
lifters that kind of puts a nail in the
coffin of this idea of okay there's no
physical differences which I don't even
know how anyone who inhabits the real
world could say to begin with but I have
heard these arguments I have heard I
have seen people try to argue that um
the reason why men are physically
stronger and faster is because of
socialization and if if girls were
raised differently and boys were raised
differently they'd be equally strong and
you're just when people say these things
I'm just kind of looking at them blankly
like what like it's a bit like it's a it
reminds me a lot of the Emperor's New
Clothes it is a kind of situation it is
I mercifully and I don't know if you
agree the UK to me seems to be at least
a little bit more touched to reality
than America now I don't know if that's
simply because most of the big
publishing and social commentator
platforms are coming from America that
you hear people like loud with crowd
roar Joe Rogan or Davin McGinnis or
whoever it might be talking about these
issues
I haven't been personally exposed to any
of it in the UK I'm you know but okay
I've seen a lot of it here really is
that an Internet or real life both well
I mean even in even in the world of
music okay all right because I've seen
this in the world of music I mean a
couple of weeks ago I was filling out a
form and it got to the section where
they compiled you know at the end of
when you fill out a form and they ask
you for your gender and ethnicity and
that kind of came from what they called
it that kind of information okay I got
to the gender section and there were
about six different options in the
drop-down list or you could put other
and write your own thing and there was a
little asterisk saying gender is not the
same as sex gender is whatever you
personally feel or identify as okay I've
seen that before I get down to ethnicity
and you can pick your own ethnicity too
alright this is on like a professional
form and so it says yeah similar similar
wording ethnicity is not the same as
race or skin color it doesn't it's not
necessarily linked to your nationality
or your origin ethnicity is defined as
what you personally feel and what you
personally identify as so according to
this form I could write down that I'm a
Native American woman and everybody is
supposed to take that 100% seriously and
you know stuff like that it's just and
that you know there's there's lots of
other things that I've seen but yeah I
mean that was in the UK that was
uk-based there's quite a bit there's
quite a there there's a lot of it's
happening in the UK too it's happening
in all the the entire Anglo sphere as
far as I'm aware UK USA Canada Australia
New Zealand I don't know if it's um
maybe the English language maybe because
we don't have gendered nouns and stuff
like that so maybe it's easier for
people to get away with this warping of
reality but um yeah so I have seen it
trickling in there and you know with
some stuff I don't there are certain
things I don't really care about there's
lots of things that I think are silly
but it's like whatever but when certain
lines start getting crossed then that's
where I feel like people do need to step
in and draw certain lines and boundaries
and go okay wait hang on this isn't a
good idea because X Y and Zed you know
having having Anthony Joshua identify as
a woman and go and compete in women's
boxing that's that's not a good idea
right that's not that's not good that's
not safe that's not fair
let's not do that right but according to
certain people's rules as long as he
feels
he's a woman then according to them
that's okay and again it's just no yeah
it's bizarre as well I I feel a lot like
I'm treading on eggshells with this sort
of stuff Steve everybody does everybody
does yes Steven woods for the guy behind
rationality rules very very big YouTube
channel philosophy and YouTube channel
do you know who do you know who I'm
referring to I think I've heard of it
but I'm not familiar rationality rules
is really good YouTube channel and this
guy understands cognitive biases ethics
and philosophy to a degree of fidelity
like pretty much probably no one a young
guy as well at just out the university
quarter of a male subs and he tread on
it got a bit of poo on issue talking
about transgender athletes and as far as
I could see on the video didn't he he
maybe didn't have wholly formed views
but it wasn't it was in no way
derogatory as far as I could see etc etc
and he gets denounced by the Atheist
Society of America which is like this
company that he's worked up towards for
his entire life and he like I don't know
you people not supposed to be the ones
that are the closest to reality the ones
that are the least sort of ideologically
bound like it should be complete reason
etc etc and then he goes on this huge
tirade apology thing and I'm no no
watching this guy he's desperately
trying to save his YouTube channel and I
get it like you know I I love his
content and it's a shame that it came to
that and maybe he did make a genuine
u-turn but how strong was the backlash
that that threatens his YouTube channel
pretty strong like I think I think more
than anything his concern was as soon as
he got ratified by this atheist Society
of America I think it might be Texas
something do you know I'm sorry do you
know I am laughing is because this this
sounds like I often I often joke that
certain atheists are more religious than
religious people yeah so when I was so
when you're talking about like this
atheist society like ostracizing this
heretic it makes me laugh because I'm
just like well that's extremely that's
like a writ that's like very really
that's a very religious sort of
thing you know what I mean that's why
funny yeah I mean our people trying to
find religion in the choice of gender
are they trying to find religion in the
adoption of a political party and stuff
like that now I know that that's
something that you have commented on
before and I thinking about it I agree
there's a Alain de Botton from the
school of life say something similar
he says the lack of connection to a
greater sense of good and a greater
sense of belonging and all of the other
things that were the trappings and the
trimmings that came along with religion
are actually what people are now trying
to substitute into their life yeah I've
been saying that for a very I've been
saying that for a very long time I've
just got a bigger megaphone now because
I've observed it
all right I've observed it the thing is
I think that fundamentally the word
religion or religious sort of weirds of
weird certain people out like they don't
they don't really like it but I think
there's almost two ideas of religion
you've got you've got organized formal
religion Christianity Judaism you know
Islam etc but there's also you know
there's also another meaning of
religious just like someone can go to
the gym religiously someone can someone
can someone can do they're there someone
can work on a computer program
religiously and people know what that
means right so there's so human beings
do as far as I'm aware like this isn't
something I've sort of scientifically
studied or any more anything this is
just anecdotal from living on the on the
earth for three decades in a bit right
is that most people are I think people
sort of have what I'd call a religious
core okay and that can be filled with an
organized religion but it can also be
filled with a strong political ideology
a strong dietary ideology you get
religious vegans you get religious
carnivores a strong idea that could be
socio-political it could be it could be
a radical feminism it could be what it
it could yes yeah well football is very
religious
professional sports is very religious
yeah I mean it's very religious it's the
same it's the same circuitry you see
what I mean is it's the same circuitry
that those things sort of act on and so
what I do find with you know I don't
want to I don't like to have a group
everybody but with you know certain
people who are atheists who are against
religion or whatever is they can often
be really just in a whole different way
you can even be a religious atheist as
far as I'm concerned right you have
people who are there more militant and
aggressive and firm in their atheism
than I am in my own Christianity yeah do
you see what I mean right I I'm kind of
like a humble religious person in that I
accept that I could be wrong yeah okay
so I believe that God exists I believe I
believe certain things but I'll be the
first to put my hands up and say you
know what I could be wrong I could I
could die and it turns out the whole
thing that I've been believing was was
just wrong
right that's entirely possible but I've
come across certain people and had
debates and it's almost like they don't
even there so from there like absolutely
no way on earth God exists like you are
totally wrong all these other billions
of people are totally wrong I know this
100% I know for certain that there's no
afterlife and I was like whoa like whoa
like to me that's weird because I'm like
I don't know that's also to me like wow
that's more hardcore yeah
not being like it via crap so it's not
it's not to rip on anyone like you do
have people who are traditionally
religious who are the same who think
absolutely this is the one true faith
and everybody else is wrong and
everybody else is going to hell and
everyone who doesn't believe exactly
what I believe is Ryan to me it's you
know that you've you've got to have a
level of humility because to me it's a
it's a faith right faith means that you
don't you accept it you don't have all
of the scientific at
and data and whatever - you know I
nobody can write some proof right the
the counter the counter to every person
who believes in God is always all what's
your proof that God exists and it's like
well in a scientific sense I can't I
can't give you like a formula or
something that will prove I can give you
like my logical rational explanation as
to why I think God exists but I can't
give you some rigorous proof that you
could in physics or in in mathematics or
something because you're talking about
you're talking about a whole different
dimension of reality as well where I
don't even think science sort of applies
you see what I mean
it's like the concept of infinity we all
kind of know what infinity is but
infinity is beyond our human capability
to understand right you can't how can
you have a number or something that
never was always there and it doesn't
like you feels like you understand it
for two seconds and then two seconds
later you don't understand if you grasp
it so trying to hold on the water in
your hands
yeah I totally totally agree a analogous
situation that's occurred recently is
this Mario Lopez debacle which just
exploded in America so for the listeners
that don't know I'm talking about the
guy that played AC Slater in Saved by
the Bell the Washington TV 20 years ago
and it's done like he's our host for MTV
and he does other bits and stuff he is
for a long time the super-clean smiley
guy on you TV fantastic teeth you know I
mean he's just there he's been super
positive
he's just getting he's getting it done
and I'm he said on a I think it was
actually a Candace Owen show yeah where
he says this and he says look I'm never
one to tell anyone how to parent their
kids obviously and I think if you come
from a place of love you really can't go
wrong but at the same time my god if
you're three years old and you're saying
you're feeling a certain way or you
think you're a boy or a girl or whatever
the case may be
I just think it's dangerous as a parent
to make that determination then and be
like okay well you're going to be a boy
or a girl
whatever the case may be it's sort of
alarming and my gosh
I just think about the repercussions
later on now that to me is almost a
pedestrian paragraph because of because
of how many caveats he's had to put in
place it's like it's I'm not this it did
I'm not being certain here and I'm just
gonna try and be polite like that in
anyone's world that is overly polite
literally like verbose in it's
politeness yeah and he got uh nigh
elated did he watch the fallout of this
I've seen some of it yeah I've seen some
of it the only mistake he made was
apologizing they cut the apology the
subsequent apology the comments I made
were ignorant and insensitive and I now
have a deeper understanding of how
hurtful they were that Lopez said in a
statement I have have been and always
will be an ardent supporter of the LGBTQ
community and I'm going to use this
opportunity to better educate myself
moving forward I'll be more informed and
thoughtful what she what's your thoughts
on that I his initial statement was
completely correct his apology was
disappointing because he should not have
apologized I know why he did of course I
underst
I can only imagine what kind of a fire
and pressure he came under from his I
don't know producers and colleagues and
co-workers and whatever but um if you're
not wrong don't apologize and especially
don't apologize to one of these crazy
mobs that just goes after you because
they go after you know they pick targets
who they think are vulnerable or weak
right it's like a herd of lions trying
to find the and antelope that's limping
yeah so that they can so if they can all
mob on them in a pack right I'll never
do it they'll never do it one-on-one but
they'll they'll come in a pack and
they'll try to attack someone and if you
stand firm then you don't back down then
48 hours later they'll find a different
target so I think you should have just
weathered the storm and
but yeah it's it's I'm a little
disappointed that he that he backed down
at the mob because I thought people
would have learned by now not to make
apologies for things You're not sorry
for if I say two plus two equals four
and someone else thinks that equals five
and they set a mob on me to try to get
me to say that it equals five I'm not
going to do it I'm gonna say no it
equals four I don't care how many people
are telling me it equals five it equals
four and the point that he made was
actually quite important because we were
talking about certain lines not being
crossed and I think two of those lines
which are sensitive which are both
things we've touched on here one of them
is when it comes to people's safety and
security okay so for example in in the
whole sports thing okay so if you've got
um in in any sort of physical contact
sport or anything like that if you have
people who are biological men competing
against women or being in their changing
rooms and stuff like that that's that's
a safety and a security concern that you
would have thought that you know anyone
who considers themself any type of you
don't even need to be a feminist right
but you would have certainly thought
that the feminine of the feminists would
be up in arms about that and I know some
of them are but just just any person
who's reasonable and concerned for women
would be like okay mmm we we don't want
to do that that's that's a bit of a
concern and then the second line that I
draw a hard line at is stuff involving
kids ma'am stuff involving children you
know I've got I'm not a parent yet but
I've got nine nieces and nephews and he
was specifically talking about the
three-year-old okay three-year-olds
don't know anything three
three-year-olds can't make decisions let
alone life-altering ones that will
affect everything from their mental
well-being to their physical bodies to
their ability to reproduce in the future
you want to let someone decide that at
the age of three that is
crazies and that's basically what he was
saying he didn't even say it in all the
words words that I am yeah but um yeah
that's that's a crazy idea that's not
that's yeah I mean
I don't even don't even have the words
for it well I mean things like my
business partner has a two-month year
old and a two and a half year old okay
and the times that I see that two and a
half year old he is easily five
different characters an hour he's an
astronaut then he's a postman then he's
then he's a dinosaur
then he's doing someone else then he's
doing an impression of daddy
then he's this that any other and you
don't take any of these things seriously
no because at that age children don't
know what's best for them which is the
exact reason why the parents are around
now the parents are around because if
left to their own devices the children
would cause some sort of catastrophe
they'd ride that they ride the dog into
a stream or they do you know I mean
something will go wrong
I know they'll kill themselves man if
you leave the average two-year-old alone
for a couple that for an hour
in a certain environment killed
themselves there's something dangerous
in that room even if you've nerved the
[ __ ] out of everything there's something
in there that they can eat or put in
their eye or do whatever it is you
totally right and yeah so here is it
child abuse is it child abuse to allow
children to make those sort of decisions
or to support those sort of decisions as
far as I'm concerned yes as far as I'm
concerned yes I don't think that um you
know once people are adults
once they're 18 plus let's say perhaps
even a little bit older when you're
thinking about brain development but
certainly say 18 plus then I mean you
can't you're not going to give and no
one wants to give a child no one thinks
that three-year-old should be able to
get a tattoo no one thinks a three-year
I mean getting a tattoo is a much more
of a minor than going on hormonal
treatment or cutting bits off of your
reproductive parts right but know what
no one would give it three-year-old a
tattoo even if they really really wanted
one I've seen some others from Newcastle
with three-year-olds ago three is
pierced though which yes no I can
understand that one more actually
weirdly slightly long-term repercussions
though yeah yeah so you know you
wouldn't give them you wouldn't give
them alcohol to drink you wouldn't let
them of course they can't consent to
consent to anything sexual
you know but and and that's that's the
disturbing thing because it's like look
if you're gonna let little kids start
consenting to things then that's a you
know some people say slippery slopes
aren't a real thing but no slippery
slopes can be a real thing and it's like
no children just do not have that agency
children need to be protective they
can't make their own decisions they
can't consent to things you can't even
let them choose what they want to eat
for dinner because they're just gonna
want to eat
Haribo yeah chicken nuggets and Haribo
and ice cream that's like you can't eat
that always every day yeah exactly kid
you've got to be a parent and be like no
okay you're gonna have some vegetables
you can have some rice you can have some
chicken and maybe you can have yeah then
you can have a couple of Haribo if
you're a good boy or a good girl so on
the other side of that fence there is an
argument that could be made from someone
from a difficult leaning in terms of how
they look at the world that says well if
you're not supporting the child in being
what they are that's child abuse the
other asset side to that they're wrong
is that because the starting point is
why we need to stick to until someone
has agency or sufficient agency yeah
and because certain things are certain
things have so what we're discussing
here is something with a permanent
life-altering consequences okay if you
are I genuinely decided that we wanted
to go on hormone therapy and live the
remainder of our lives
as a woman you know Oh Chris Christine
yeah I guess you could still be Chris
yep
then people can have their ideas about
that and I may have some reasons why I'm
skeptical about that personally but
you're a grown man
I'm a grown man and you're an adult and
you have agency and if that's the choice
you make then you know you can you can
do it okay
but um if you are a child and someone
wants to put you on hormone blockers or
audun test all
stirone or on Eastridge in or start
having surgeries to I mean that's going
to affect you for the remainder of your
life and it's well known that most
people who experience any kind of gender
dysphoria in their young age most people
get over it within a relatively short
space of time and it's not even that
uncommon for example if you've got a
little boy who's got say they've got
three older sisters okay it's not that
rare that that little boy at some little
point might be oh I want to I want to be
a girl or he might want to wear his his
sister's shoes or her dress or whatever
just because they're surrounded by women
and that's but that doesn't mean that
that boy is a girl it doesn't mean that
oh he's actually a girl so we need to
put him on hormones and make sure he
doesn't go through puberty property and
properly and whatever and that'll affect
them I mean that's when they do become a
reproductive age they they what then
won't might not be able to reproduce
they'll be infertile they won't be able
to have their own children they may go
through all kinds of psychological
problems and issues and physical
development issues I mean lord knows
what kind of can of worms you're opening
so to let somebody that young make those
kind of decisions is utterly it's
reprehensible as far as I'm concerned
it's an it's amazing to me that it even
sort of needs to be explained like I
sometimes there's certain things I was
like man how am I even needing are we
engaged in this yeah why do I even need
to justify my position here and it's
such a it's such a new thing it's such a
localized thing I mean if you go around
the world if you go to anywhere in
Africa anywhere in South America and
almost anywhere in Asia anywhere in the
Middle East and you start talking about
that they'll look at you like you are a
complete crazy person they'll be like
what on earth are you talking about that
a two-year-old boy can you know like
what do you mean right they'll they'll
want to lock you up for even talking
about it they're the same species
same genome yeah it's just if they're
not not experiencing the same the same
situations one of the things that I keep
on thinking about and it obviously it's
apparent in Mario Lopez's
apology is the equivalent exponential
growth that you've seen is the same
slippery slope on the other side that
people can get pushed down from one step
of saying maybe it's not a tremendously
good idea to let three-year-old to
change the gender to your transphobic
and it's this exponential increase it's
a bullying tactic that's all it is it's
just a tactic right people know that if
you slap a label on somebody whether
that's racist sexist homophobic
transphobic whatever Islamophobic
whatever phobia or label people can try
to slap on someone people do this all
day it's nothing new it's just a cheap
way to try to discredit someone it's
simply a tactic and it's a it's a really
disgusting one firstly because it's
slanderous and secondly because it
minimizes it dilutes the terms okay if
you call everybody who disagrees with
you racist then you're diluting the term
for you're diluting what racism actually
is and your diet you're minimizing harm
that's caused by genuine racism and
you're also providing cover for actual
racists okay if I've heard the term race
I see it slung around so much now both
in real life and on Twitter that I'm
myself I'm pretty desensitized to it
okay if someone's like oh that guy's a
racist my first you know if you went
back 15 years ago my gut would be to
believe them and to be like oh oh what's
going on whereas now my gut is to be
like oh gosh okay with someone do you do
you mean do you mean they're actually a
real racist or do you just mean that
they're a little bit right-wing or
they're a bit or they're conservative or
they like Trump or you know and it's
it's it's gotten zillion people are just
amping up this rhetoric all the time
you're getting people on Twitter saying
oh everybody who supports Trump every
single one of you is supporting white
nationalism I'm like what about the
black guys and the Latinos and the black
women and all the Arab people who all
like Trump I mean you'reyou're saying
they're all white nationalists like come
on just think like stop using such
ridiculous
you hear criticizing Trump for his
rhetoric while staying saying stuff
that's far more inflammatory and
divisive than anything that comes out of
his mouth so it's just people just need
to kind of take a step back and chill it
does it just stop us from getting to the
nuance of the discussion as well right
because as soon as you go from being
anything which isn't zero if you as soon
as you add a one or two or three all the
way up to 100 you get pushed to 100 when
your stops stops the ability to have the
virtuous middle which is actually where
the Devils in the details right and the
rubber meets the road at the point where
people want to find out what's the
that's the reason I enjoy doing this
podcast I like to deconstruct stuff so I
can find out exactly where the rubber
meets the road with particular issues
and it's one of the most interesting
things I think you can do when you're
conversing with people but as soon as
like you say someone that you disagree
with gets given a ism or a movie obeah
and well positions over yeah they tried
it with me it didn't work what what isms
and OB is did they give you um
sexism and transphobia okay yeah both
for the same tweet as well but it
doesn't stick because it doesn't work I
just make people look stupid when they
call me anything like that and
ultimately it's not true so I don't care
if someone says if someone calls me
sexist I will literally laugh in their
face okay I might even agree and amplify
just to like make a joke right I'll tell
them that it's not ridiculous yeah it's
that ridiculous I'll tell them to I
don't know get back in the kitchen or
whatever even if it's a guy who says it
just like whatever it's such a dumb
thing to say anybody who knows me knows
that I'm not sexist so I don't I'm not
gonna go on the defensive and start
claiming my righteousness it's just like
just no go away like if you call someone
something their appropriate answer if
someone accuses you of something with no
evidence and that you're not is to you
know call a call them an a-hole because
that's what their being no really if
someone just came up to you Kristen was
like oh you're racist then you don't
need to you don't need to start
justifying why you're not you don't need
to go on that they want you to go on the
defensive yeah right you don't go on the
defensive you just say no well you
being a jerk you're a jerk is you have
no evidence that I am and I'm not and
you're accusing me of being this thing
so if you wanna have a conversation stop
being a jerk and we can talk or they
don't conversation over but people
always feel this need to and defend
themselves and you know people who
attack in these mobs they're very like
they're like sharks in the water right
so since there's a little bit of blood
oh god we got him yeah we got him we got
him you know and then they try to find
another target and they keep trying to
do it to all these different people and
you know most people you know they they
do the false apology and they they say
that you know I because the funny thing
okay and that in that Mario Lopez thing
at no point did he say why how or why
what he said was wrong yeah right he
said I'm a sensitive deeper
understanding it's like this it's it's
like you go on to obeah apology calm
that you know you put in a certain
number of characteristics and then it
speeds out this thing because you know I
mentioned earlier on rationality rules
and Stephens the first five minutes of
his response video with that it was that
language that exact language right there
and like it's like a struggle session
yeah yeah you know in the Soviet Union
and in Mao's China when they used to get
people to admit to crimes that they that
they hadn't committed right and they
just get people and they just have to
say confess to something they won't
yeah whatever it is it's like a new-age
version of that way you put people up
especially public figures you put them
up on this thing and they have to give
this false apology or admission to a
kind of atone for those their sins
and then okay they can maybe come back
in the club otherwise they get cancelled
that's that that's the new term but I
just think people need to really stop
giving in to this I mean it's it's
incredible how many um I get so many
messages and emails now from people
especially in the world of entertainment
also in the world of tech and in media
who one tell me that I'm extremely brave
for being as honest and frank as I am
but then to say that oh they can't speak
out because they're worried about losing
their job or they're worried about
losing this opportunity or all this kind
of stuff
it's just it's crazy I mean we're
supposed to be in a free country with
free speech and freedom of expression
both in the UK and in the USA so the
idea that people are essentially
succumbing to a form of terrorism as far
as its its terrorism isn't it right if
you are you know making people come so
afraid of their repercussions to say
what's on their mind or to express their
genuine beliefs or whatever because
you're you're terrorizing them and you
know you're you're making examples out
of other people too so to show what will
happen if they step out of line that's
it's terrorism it's a murder if the
heads on spikes as you literally it is
Mario's head is currently sat on a spike
outside of outside of the TV studio and
the worst thing you made a really good
point about the fact that it dilutes
down the people who are actually the
problem and it also doesn't allow those
of us who have compassion are my my
empathy is crippling like absolutely
crippling for almost anything I spoke
about Daniel's loss a comedian with this
and we said that you know you see those
videos of dogs coming home to soldiers
like after they've been at war and I'm
just like bawling my eyes out of these
things and I can't bear but the the
problem is that if you do want to have
compassion and try and understand
complex situations and someone who is
going through gender dysphoria is
someone who has suffered with racism etc
etc etc it's like to be able to to be
able to step into that room and try and
understand that you also have to do all
this other stuff as well you are wrong
you have to put this bag on and this bag
on and this bag on and yeah it's it's
not very it's not very helpful so I
think you're right it'll be interesting
to see how many more Mario Lopez's there
are and how many more zoo bees there are
it's like five years you know I mean
like that's that's gonna be interesting
and because of the way that popular
culture defines and it trickles down
into defining what everybody else thinks
it's not actually gonna take lots of
those situations to occur to actually
begin defining culture like ahead of it
I don't know you know a lot of those
situations can be like the stone in the
river that directs the flow a little bit
so one of the other things I want you to
discuss is a titanium McGrath I don't
know how to pronounce her name titania
titanium a great on you
- Tonya McGrath yeah so I have this is
the first time that the listeners will
hear it I've managed to confirm her /
her character to come on the podcast my
gold she's currently performing
Edinburgh Fringe if you are at the
Fringe 9:00 p.m. every night I suggest
that you go and see the show has had
fantastic reviews already what I wanted
to do was to get the actress that plays
her to sit down and to have Andrew Doyle
the man who's behind her as her
publicist and I wanted to have this back
and forth apparently one of the
agreements is that the actress won't
won't speak in character on interviews
which is really a really good idea
because I mean if people actually begin
thinking that she is her all hell will
break loose but there was a tweet that
came out that is probably the best one I
think I've seen her do which is if you
only have sex with people you find
attractive you might want to ask
yourself why you're such a superficial
bigoted gosh I think my favorite one was
that being a cyst white male is an act
of violence or something one of the
things that's super interesting about
this is because Andrews British right
and also the whole the fact that he got
out staged you are like a typo from some
book publishing thing I don't know
whether you saw this but the only
reasons like I said he never wanted to
he never wanted to be the person that's
like behind this account right for the
people that don't know what we're
talking about is a a fake social justice
warrior account such as satirically
going through saying these sort of
things the absolute extreme example of
what you might see on Twitter got banned
then people I on you can't ban this it's
a satire account these are actually
allowed under Twitter Terms of Service
it's stipulated its satire comics etc
and due to some some guy a book
publishing thing accidentally fired on
some blog somewhere
that it was Andrew as the author and
then everybody trickled down because
he's the same guy that is behind
Jonathan PI as well
- Jonathan PI there's some writing
former yeah yeah so you know and
apparently now it's just like the all
hell as soon as yourself at all all hell
broke loose
but yeah the the fact that the fact that
he's got that understanding that nuance
strikes it what I was talking about in
the UK again because again for me this
sort of stuff like sis mail and and the
superficial bigotry and stuff it's it's
not language that I hear it isn't okay
and it's interested in you so V you have
but yeah I absolutely can't wait to you
you might be protected up there you're
in Newcastle right yes yeah you might
actually be somewhat insulated from it
up there you think is it's a bit less
cosmopolitan than London somewhere like
that it's a little bit more yeah and
people I know a Newcastle well and
people in Newcastle are just yeah a bit
more in touch and grounded yeah so in
sort of saying yeah a lot of these ideas
it's a bit like how in the US like if
you go to the south of the USA or you're
sort of in Middle America in the Midwest
you're gonna get far less of these
social you getting get far less social
justice nonsense right they're not
they're not running around in in Houston
and you know most parts of Texas in
Arizona and Kentucky and Alabama all
right there's no social justice warriors
there but if you go to Portland you go
to Los Angeles you go to New York you go
to you know the coastal cities then
that's where a lot more of this ideology
is based so in the UK I mean if you're
in London or in Brighton I was gonna say
what's like whoa kissed city in the UK
Brighton brightens the bloke right to be
in the UK easy it easily no way easily
yeah yes yeah brights and easily yeah
brightens the one place where you would
encounter people who do genuinely yeah
who use this kind of language and well
you'll you'll say something lots of the
things that we've said here they'd find
extremely offensive and want us to
apologize for and
start giving you a lecture on you know
why you as a privileged sis white male
should not be you know saying certain
things or perhaps you should even be
speaking to me in a certain way as a
person of color and all they're all all
that stuff should you be speaking to you
in a certain way as a person of color I
don't even I hate that term I don't even
use it it's just silly yeah it's it's
really interesting Joe Rogan recently
went through a breakdown of person of
color and colored person and like the
fact that you can rearrange the same
words in a sentence in one ways like
currently accepted and in one way was
accepted but now isn't accepted yeah
yeah it's it's it's silly I don't I
don't use I don't use terminology of my
ideological opponents shall we say
although I don't I don't like to view
people as opponents I like to just view
people as people but I guess I oppose
certain ideas okay I try I try not to I
try to separate people from ideas so
I've encountered people who you know
have some of these bizarre ideas and I I
don't agree with them on them but as
long as we can have a conversation and
be decent to each other and you know
maybe agreed to disagree maybe we'll
change each other's minds on on certain
things from time to time then it's it's
it's all good but I don't think it's uh
yeah there's just some ideas that I
don't think are a net benefit to society
so anything that I feel is that way then
I will most likely oppose yeah I
understand
so to finish off one of the things that
I wanted to ask I appreciate that you
understand this with a lot of new ones
and you are someone who it seems kind of
similar to Jordan Peters in a little way
like the way that when the Left decided
to pick on him it's like they picked on
the wrong [ __ ] guy oh and it's like
the same with you like if there was
someone that was gonna come to the front
it was going to be someone who like
overtly could be first off classed as a
minority so you've got that card to play
like whenever you want right you've got
like the race card in your pocket
and then you've got the ability
lyrically to write to speak to do all of
these different things you are someone
who I feel is you know hopefully well
equipped to deal with whatever the [ __ ]
the futures got in store for you go and
enjoy and so that is going to make a big
change so some of the people that are
out there how would you suggest that
they go about viewing the world tools or
tactics with regards to skepticism or
conduct or however you think you've got
some advice for people about how they
navigate the next sort of 2 2 years 5
years Wow
well you mentioned Jordan Peterson so
I'll take one of his rules which is tell
the truth or at least don't lie right I
think that's important I'm really big on
authenticity and I always have been both
in my music and outside of it you know
just trying to be honest and not say
things that maybe are beneficial or
might seem expedient in the short term
but in the long term are likely to do
you damage or get you caught in some
sort of web of lies so just being honest
and then and then yeah that goes further
to sort of standing your ground standing
your ground but also being not in not as
in digging yourself in on an idea and
not allowing other people to challenge
it no no no that do the opposite of that
get outside of your echo chamber but um
don't be afraid don't crumble at the
first question right if someone if
someone challenges something or someone
wants you to apologize for something
that you're not sorry for then you don't
have to apologize and it would be it
would be an empty apology anyway if I do
something and I'm not sorry about it and
I'm forced into some kind of apology
then I'm still not sorry about it it's
just you're just saying yeah I said the
words but that doesn't really that
doesn't really mean anything and then
beyond that I guess just being being
trying to be open minded and talk to
different people of different viewpoints
and you know if you've got something
that you are or and and you know just be
willing to learn and be willing to have
your mind changed it's it's a
the the reason any of us know anything
is because we've been wrong in the past
okay pretty much everything you know is
because you are wrong at some point so
if you are never wrong or you feel like
you're never wrong you're probably not
learning anymore probably not dating the
OS approach exactly exactly every day
you should you should be being wrong
about something almost every day nothing
catastrophic right yeah but um yeah you
should be oh okay someone I say
something and then you're like oh no
actually that it uh look at this is the
data or these are the facts or have you
thought this you know if I'm being
intellectually honest if it's a better
argument or it's a fact that goes
against what I believed it's okay no
you're right and then I incorporate that
it's my thing and then hopefully the
next time you have a conversation with
the next person you're a little bit
wiser and that continues to happen and I
kind of look forward to um it's one
reason I'm not so worried about getting
older it's like I look forward to seeing
just how much I'll know and the whole
were kind of person I'll be in ten years
in 15 years and 20 years because that's
when yeah that's when it should all
start peaking and I think that's why
someone like Jordan Peterson his rise
has just been crazy because it's really
interesting I mean it's rare for someone
to become world famous in their mid-50s
isn't it
but it's almost but you were talking
about that
that's striking and it's like he's been
building up and building up and building
up and then he's sort of having a
century of yeah when the spotlight came
on him it was like oh my god this is you
fools this isn't even my final form
Phoenix just sort of like were like
absolutely this is a force you know yeah
but had the spotlight been on him maybe
20 years ago or 30 years ago it wouldn't
have been he wouldn't have formulated
his ideas and been able to articulate
them in the in the way that he does
which is very masterful I went to see
him live last year and it was was really
interesting it's really where did you
see him
Oxford oh cool I saw him at the
Manchester Show Manchus show is
fantastic as well yeah yeah and it's
really interesting because it's yeah I
mean it's weird he's touring like a rock
star just doing these talks shout about
things that you could not pay me to go
and you couldn't have paid me to go and
learn about that 15 years ago and now
I'm Maya put my hand in my pocket yeah
it's interesting and you know it's so
tropi now to talk about John Pearson but
being precise with your speech telling
the truth being friends with people that
want the best for you all of those sort
of things
they're fantastic rules to live by yeah
I really a genuinely genuinely do hope
that there is a Jordan Pederson future
ahead for you man I think that you you
know tentatively I hope that you have
the skills to to navigate this space and
to be a really a really interesting
balancing voice going forward obviously
we need to get another 15 kilos on you
squat but once we've done that I you
know I really do think that there'll be
a lot of a lot of world that you feed
for you to kind of play around with and
i genuinely I'm super excited to see
what the next the next year's sort of
particularly for yourself has in store
I'm very feeling very fortunate to
hopefully be a part of that Genesis
process and kind of help you along the
way as well I appreciate that Chris
thank you very much man
today's been awesome anybody who wants
to find out anymore get at zubi music on
twitter where else can they go is the
website anything else yeah sure so I'm
on Twitter at Zoo B music same handle on
Instagram YouTube and Facebook as well
at Zoo be music and my website is zoo B
music com
I've also got a merchandise over site
where you can get my music and merch
which is team Zoo be calm fantastic all
links to everything that we've spoken
about we will be in the show notes below
if you've got any comments or any
feedback about today obviously it's
quite a nuanced and interesting
conversation the comments are always
open or actress relax wherever you
follow me but for now sue be man thank
you so much good luck with Jo when
you're out in the States and I'll catch
you next time thanks but I appreciate it
have a good evening
[Music]
you